hola muy buenas noches gracias por
continuar en la pantalla de france 24
estamos de regreso para conocer las
principales noticias en materia
económica de américa latina y del resto
del mundo y por eso nos acompaña por
supuesto daniela hablando muy buenas
noches también a vamos a comenzar en
méxico donde hay una protesta de
embajadores de walmart verdad claro que
si santiago muy buenas noches mire hay
un programa en ese país hace muchos años
liderado por el instituto nacional de
las personas adultas mayores para que
los privados les permitan a las personas
de la tercera edad trabajar por ejemplo
como empacadores en el caso de wal mart
pero la pandemia de amenaza con que se
acabe esa práctica después de un año en
casa los empacadores de más de 60 años
de edad esperaban retornar a sus
trabajos el mes pasado cuando se
relajaron las restricciones en ciudad de
méxico pero la filial mexicana del
gigante estadounidense dijo que no lo
iba a permitir provocando protestas al
frente de sus almacenes y el crimen los
razones santiago primero porque la
pandemia ha hecho que la gente ya no
quiera que terceros toquen sus productos
y segundo porque se están eliminando las
bolsas plásticas y los clientes llevan
reutilizables y no necesitan ayuda para
empacar lamentar las consecuencias de la
pandemia vamos ahora a brasil el gigante
sudamericano está cerca de privatizar lo
que es su compañía eléctrica que va a
suceder bueno mire se llama eletrobrás
que es la mayor empresa eléctrica del
país y de américa latina y el gobierno
busca abrir un proceso de capitalización
con el que va a reducir su participación
en la compañía del 60 por ciento al 45
el senado yo le dio el visto bueno y
ahora pasa a discusión en la cámara de
diputados antes de ir a sanción
presidencial el gobierno de ayer
bolsonaro calcula que el proceso podría
suponer ingresos cercanos a los 12 mil
millones de dólares la importancia
santiago de esta empresa radica en que
produce una tercera parte de la
electricidad que consume el país y tiene
casi la mitad de las líneas de
transmisión vamos a ir ahora a líbano no
da tregua en este país la crisis
económica y ahora se suma lo que es la
eliminación de subsidios un nuevo
anuncio santiago lo hizo el ministerio
de energía
ese país de medio oriente que está
sumido en una grave crisis económica
advirtió a los ciudadanos que pronto se
pondrá fin al esquema de subsidios de
combustible esto vale unos seis mil
millones de dólares al año para el
erario y mantiene el costo de la
gasolina en apenas una quinta parte de
su valor real pero el problema en líbano
va más allá el desabastecimiento hace
interminables las filas para llenar
muchas veces apenas una cuarta parte del
tanque de gasolina y mientras muchos en
el mundo están trabajando desde casa en
el líbano otros lo hacen desde su carro
como este desarrollador web estoy en una
reunión mientras espero el combustible
no sé qué decir el gobierno del líbano
nos está empujando al límite no se está
poniendo a prueba y lanzando todo tipo
de desafíos bueno daría vamos a
continuar ahora con una preocupación con
la cual empatizamos no hay preocupación
sobre el futuro del whisky en eeuu y el
reino unido- que va a pasar sobre todo
el viernes empatizamos con eso los
fabricantes de escoceses de whisky
soltaron un suspiro de alivio esta
semana cuando washington y bruselas
dieron
una tregua en su eterna disputa por
subsidios aeronáuticos como lo
informamos a pesar de que reino unidos
ya no es parte del bloque también se va
a beneficiar de este pacto pues el
whiskey ha sido quizás el producto más
afectado en esta batalla del lado de
gran bretaña el gremio que reúne a los
productores dice que desde que donald
trump e impuso un arancel del 25 por
ciento hace 18 meses las ventas a eeuu
han han bajado casi un 30 por ciento
pero hay desconcierto en el sector
porque washington suspender a ese
gravamen al whisky escocés
pero reino unido- no era lo propio con
el whisky estadounidense porque ese fue
impuesto en el marco de otra disputa
legal por el acero y el aluminio y que
dicen los indicadores de la jornada o
street o cerró su peor semana desde
octubre después de que la reserva
federal dejara entrever que va a subir
sus tasas de interés antes de lo
previsto las bolsas europeas se
encerraron una mala semana influencia
también por los mismos anuncios de la
fed
en américa latina siguió la misma
tendencia de sao paulo rompió una racha
negativa de tres días pero pierde en la
semana y cerramos como siempre con la
cifra del día cuales dos mil 740
millones de dólares que mackenzie scott
que es la mujer más rica del mundo y ex
esposa del dueño de amazon va a donar a
286 organizaciones filantrópicas ella y
su actual marido dicen que sería mejor
si la riqueza desproporcionada no
estuviera concentrada en unas pocas
manos de la muchísimas gracias por esta
completísima crónica económica a nuestra
audiencia le invitamos a seguir
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y en france24 punto com
sigan con nosotros